you've just hit credits on Resident Evil
4 and you're all set to put the game
down and move on to something else but
wait
there's a small itchy feel new game
pluses right there I bet hardcore would
be a ton of fun plus there's plenty of
guns to upgrade and Leon would look
really cute in those cat ears
follow this feeling
culture
hello stranger and welcome to nohud the
show all about finding new and
interesting ways to play your favorite
video games
today we're looking at Resident Evil 4
and why it's a huge mistake to stop
after your first playthrough that's
because Resident Evil 4 has so much more
to offer past a first time experience
I'm talking gameplay changes on higher
difficulties unlockables that offer fun
bonuses and a whole host of challenges
to pursue the game is a master class in
replayability with new layers to it with
each run and peeling them back reveals
one of the most highly replayable
single-player experiences of all time
stranger
even during that first playthrough
Resident Evil 4 is already priming you
for your second man maybe even a third
it accomplishes this by not giving you
everything in a single playthrough and
in doing so lays down these seeds for
you to pick it up again you likely
unlocked a bunch of challenges something
you might not really have paid attention
to but hey these seem doable and the
rewards are really cool looking and of
course in classic Resident Evil fashion
the game gives you a grade and a run
time at the end and uh oh uh uh a b rank
I
I guess that's pretty good but I mean
like you could shave down a few hours
you know a game is something special
when you're already planning that next
playthrough while still working on the
first what challenges should I go for
what weapon should I use what charm
should I accessorize with most
importantly what costume should I wear
cat ears
[Music]
not yet
foreign
now you can always start with a fresh
save but I think it is best to jump
right into New Game Plus on a higher
difficulty Resident Evil games have a
history of creative higher difficulties
that are more than just enemies you go
harder and the same is true for Resident
Evil 4. on Hardcore enemy variety and
placement is mixed up keeping you on
your toes puzzles are made more complex
and if you bump things up even further
too professional only perfect parries
work and there's no Auto saves the leap
from standard to hardcore alone is
substantial so much so that I wouldn't
recommend it as a first time experience
it can be rather painful if you aren't
prepared and yet it sings on New Game
Plus where you get to bring in a fully
Decked Out briefcase but don't get cocky
you cool jacket swoopy hair hunky you
sure you might suplex your way into a
new game plus on Hardcore with a fully
locked and loaded Arsenal letting you
blast through gonados the badass cool
guy you are but as the game goes on the
difficulty ramps up and it still proves
to be quite the challenge
this all makes your second playthrough
feel just as fresh as the first now
you're truly starting to flex those
combat muscles you've been building up
all this time
[Music]
it's not just about the difficulty
though Resident Evil 4 hits you with
dozens of challenges that can be
attempted and completed during many
playthrough this is where things start
to get really interesting because some
of these force you to shake up your
playstyle most of the game's big set
pieces offer a unique alternate
challenge some are straightforward but
difficult like taking zero damage during
the minecart sequence others are a real
son of a [__] like defeating Verdugo
without bathing them in liquid nitrogen
there's also more long-term challenges
like minimalist which asks you to
complete the game using only a pistol
and a knife that sounds tough but the
game actually sets you up thanks to
another challenge destroying all 16
clockwork castallins this rewards you
with an indestructible knife an
invaluable tool to help complete
minimalist and that's when you notice
that all of these challenges and rewards
start to really Loop into one another
it's not just about doing one it's about
how completing one gives you a reward
that then makes the other one even
easier to complete and that's not the
only reward you can unlock there are a
host of bonus goodies that give real
incentive to do these challenges like
how about pairing that sweet pinstripe
suit with the Chicago sweeper Gane rank
on Hardcore congratulations Ashley has a
suit of armor so you uh you just you
don't need to worry about her anymore
she's fine the game has now rewarded you
for all your hard work by devolving into
some good old-fashioned video game
nonsense I mean for God's sakes they let
you buy the infinite rocket launcher on
New Game Plus surely the game has shown
you all it has to offer at this point
or has it
[Music]
Resident Evil 4 is the kind of game that
makes you want to try speed running and
what I mean by that is the game is
encouraging you to try to beat it as
fast as possible to master its mechanics
to become a true Resident Evil 4
connoisseur and it helps that the game
is built to be exploited in some really
really cool ways the most striking
example that has made the rounds is the
ability to skip the game's Infamous
opening Village by shooting the church
bell tower but it doesn't stop there as
this game is filled with little details
like this there's almost a if you can
imagine it the devs probably thought of
it type mentality here we all know the
rocket launcher is a great tool to
One-Shot bosses but what about
environmental obstacles
easy want to skip a padlock door well
just toss a well-placed grenade through
the window
same goes for this AA gun
or this wall during the wrecking ball
sequence
or how about a more game-breaking cheese
like placing a bunch of Mines where you
know a boss will spawn in
foreign
these are all really silly and a ton of
fun to do but they also serve a greater
purpose as an important tool for the
game's ultimate Challenge obtaining S
Plus rank on professional this
monstrosity requires you to play
professional on a brand new game meaning
no carrying over any weapons or upgrades
you need to complete it in under five
and a half hours and can only save 15
times which yeah is less than one save
per chapter accomplishing this run is no
small task requiring you to employ every
trick in the book to pull it off in a
way playing the game multiple times on
New Game Plus learning the encounters
and mastering the combat has prepared
you with the knowledge to succeed plus
completing those other challenges helps
as well because you get to bring in any
bonus rewards you unlocked such as
Ashley's Invincible armor the
unbreakable knife and the Chicago
sweeper which gets infinite ammo as its
exclusive upgrade meaning you can make
things a little easier on yourself
it's still really hard Bo but it's all
worth it when huntingin finally bestows
you with that coveted S Plus you're
rewarded with a sense of pride a few
other challenges and gaming can bring
but even more importantly you're finally
given those sweet sweet cat ears
what did the cat ears do again oh they
uh give you infinite ammo
whether intentional or not Resident Evil
4 is an incredible example of how
replaying a game can be just as if not
more rewarding than the first
playthrough the game incorporates player
Advantage into its gameplay loot letting
you bring your tools and knowledge with
you it's designed to be poked at and
broken embracing alternate strategies it
all feels incredibly considered and can
truly be appreciated and recognized with
multiple playthroughs Resident Evil 4 is
already an incredibly rewarding game on
one playthrough alone but it's all the
more impressive how it continues to
subvert players with each loop it's also
just incredibly cathartic to one shot
this [__] with a rocket launcher to the
face or this
hey everyone thanks for watching this
first episode of no HUD we air new
episodes every Wednesday so if you
enjoyed this we hope to see you next
week but that's not all you have to look
forward to GameSpot is actually
launching a whole host of new shows such
as how it's saved where Dave Klein dives
into gaming history 3 and the game's
mascots and people that save their
series from obscurity the first episode
is all about how the original Resident
Evil 4 brought much needed change to an
at the time declining franchise to
celebrate all these great new shows
we're actually doing a gosh dang
giveaway be sure to check out the pin
comment below for info on how you can
win one of many prizes including
resident before remake Jedi Survivor or
even a PlayStation 5. available to us
residents only terms and conditions
apply all right
Mary killed Leon Louise Ada uh oh okay
yeah
for sure I mean you know I'll marry Leon
yeah yeah yeah until uh I'll kill Lewis
yeah yeah I don't feel good about it no
I don't either but I mean I think I
think that's the right choice yeah